exceptionnellement les enfants avaient
le droit de veiller un peu plus tard ce
samedi 19 janvier au programme pour
cette nuit de la lecture à montigny le
bretonneux lecture d'histoires pour
petits et grands coloriage ou encore
fresque participative
l'idée c'est de donner à voir la
bibliothèque autrement en soirée dans
une ambiance assez particulière les
enfants sont captivés les parents aussi
il nous fait participer enfin il ya
toutes les dimensions qui font que on
passe un bon moment c'est vraiment très
bien une soirée autour de la découverte
du continent américain sous toutes ses
formes compte folklore gastronomie et
danse lorsqu'on a aimé c'est le côté un
peu international avec des lectures en
espagnol en anglais
et puis la diversité s'aimer lancement
de la lecture de la musique de la danse
de la culture en général quand il se
réveilla des morts autour de lui l'été
la plaine de clarté autre ambiance à la
commanderie d'elancourt où la lumière
tamisée était de rigueur au coeur de
l'exposition memento corpus une
quinzaine de comédiens et poètes se sont
succédé sur scène toute la soirée thèmes
choisis pour leur déclamation la lecture
sur tout ce qui tourne autour de la
lecture du mot delà de la phrase de la
bibliothèque du métier du livre c'est un
lieu d'échangés formidable parce que on
est tous là les uns et les autres des
gens qui sont dans le théâtre ou dans la
lecture etc et on vient un peu se
montrer chacun basque on a en magasin
est ce qu'on sait faire
c'est donc reprendre des bouquins qu'on
a trouvé dans mon pays